Michael Irvin was at my wedding because
Suzie worked with him at Fox Sports for
so many years ran into him in New York
City back in 2003 asked him if he had a
an electric blue tuxedos why he asked if
he had a tuxedo in town he said yes
where can I show up he showed up to the
wedding wearing an electric blue tuxedo
and then when my daughter was born now
six years ago and she was born god bless
Suzie we induced to avoid the opening of
the NFL season this is a fact back in
2013
so we had a baby-naming on a Saturday
right before a football Sunday and the
rabbi she says to us we have a sort of a
speaker's role in my service anybody
could speak to the group who do you have
and I said Michael Irvin and Susie's
just like a million percent what a
stroke of genius can't go wrong so when
I say I love this man it's got more than
just to do with the fact that I love
working with him on NFL Network and
looking at him on NFL gameday morning
across the way and giving him so much
grief for his Dallas Cowboys as much as
I love - Michael Irvin how are you sir I
did hear that law that you just tossed
back my way and I appreciate it I want
to say hello to your NBC audience there
they go they've never heard fine work
you do I did just say tuning and they
will be blessed for it yes sir it was a
great moment rich to walk through
Central Park that's right
circular part in an electric blue suit
that was soon after I retired so so I'm
walking through enemy territory beating
up on all giant scenes for all of those
years it was quite fun and it was great
all my friends were like saying to me so
why was Michael Irvin in your wedding
what why was he why was he there and I'm
like that's my wife that's part of the
reason why I married her he's just you
never know you never know who sues he
knows so and
you're you you were you were there for
the most important day of my life so
clearly that's amazing then you spoke of
my baby naming my daughter's baby behind
of the beauty of family and the
importance of family which it's
obviously a time like now Irv is as
important as messages ever now let me
share with people too because you know I
mean being an african-american and you
you know you
I mean been a spiritual man you a Jewish
guy and my last name urban and people
always call it earth theme so we fit
right in talked about that but what I
what I don't want people to miss is the
crux of what I talked about and I love I
mean I and I got emotional talking about
it because it's true you know one of the
things that I often talk yet yeah talk
about one of my pet peeves or
fatherlessness
issues that we have in this country and
I I took through all the time we're 30
percent Caucasian American sister
percent Hispanic America's 73 percent
African American women having babies out
of wedlock fathers not being on their
post
so after talk about that at that said
him a baby name is ceremony then later
on in the Jewish Jewish community you
have a more missiles that these are
moments that kids look back on and
connect to who they are supposed to be
baby name is ceremony everybody there
they talk about what the name means they
ask favor l it's computable I guess or I
won't say upset because I don't want
african-american feel matter but I just
feel that we can be more directed we
spend the same money we call it a baby
shower or sweet 16 but it doesn't have
connectivity to the kids life it's just
a moment of spending money with Jewish
community do we need to do in every
community some things we need to steal
from other people and this is one that I
hope African Americans will spill from
the Jewish community and I believe it'll
bring that number down 473 down down
down which I think will make it all a
better world I'm sorry I don't mean
going that rich
no Irv I just love your passion and your
dedication but it's called sampling it's
sent let's not use stealing it's okay
you use a sample from the Jewish faith
that's fine that's no problem
michael irvin here on the Rich Eisen
show let's get into the the cowboys of
it all
Irv the signing of Andy Dalton means
what what does it mean what do you think
it means they got the same good money at
me that's what it means and they got a
good backup because they only had some
for us as the backup and you get a
better one like and you're gone it's a
smart decision when you can do it for a
base of identity or 3 million I know the
report is up to 7 million but that's
that's what incentives you got a
guarantee or 3 million you had so many
people to pay so getting in the dog as
an insurance policy at that number it's
a good price but it's not anything that
I'm going to jump over a moon about you
know what I mean jump over the moon is
oh my god we got into dog look but it is
a good situational price for the Cowboys
in a good backup for that but he is back
up and please rich don't nobody get into
this talking about business or 410 in
any way or this is any kind of
reflection on that because it's not that
at all this is that Christine but every
team needs a backup just in case so you
know your ear you're already hearing it
and I saw to that that they're you know
Doc's not going to Cabo this summer
right
I mean like he's we're gonna we're gonna
see him one way or another signing a
tender or a long-term deal right I hope
so if you're making three million
dollars and you say you know what I'm
going to sit out and wait on a long-term
deal it's another
when you got dead at 334 million dollar
staring at you you can make us three
meals somewhere you can't make a 34 know
where you see what I'm saying you know
so I believe that in whatever scenario
he has planned out
none will require and I don't think any
will have him leaving
Oh million Miller's on the table it's a
34 million million it was a fourth-round
draft who made two million dollars last
year no he'll be on that football field
it's just a matter when they get him on
the football field and how long they
have him on the football field but we
will get that Prescott on the football
field he's a smart man
he's not going to let that get away
Michael Irvin here on the Rich Eisen
show looks like daca or Dalton
what if should he get in the game he's
gonna have an 88 to throw to ERV walk me
through see deal am getting this number
down your thoughts on the subject
interesting you know rich as you know I
like to reach out to young guys that are
coming out to me special my wide
receivers and and not to see lamb has
had in any issue the Jews at issue but
especially if they had an issue cuz you
know in college anything I want to just
reach out and let him know hey I use me
as a resource in any way certainly my
track record
hadn't been spotless so you know any
wonder if you have some setbacks you
want to talk to me about trying to come
back from that setback I'm here and I
reached out to God's [ __ ] Julian
always God I have that I did not reach
out the city lamb I was about to but he
called me and he called me talking about
the 88 you know he was saying Michael
you know I talk about 88 you know I know
I said I want to wear number 10 and he
said I want to I want to wear number 10
I'm saying that out of honor for you and
respect for all you've done
you made 88 you've earned the right to
have that as your number he said you
know I want to go and carve out my own I
said that's great man I said whatever
makes you get up in the morning and
attack today to go be a winner that's
what you do you know for me we're in 88
I woke up
and I saw through Pearson I told to
Pearson is the first guy to interview me
when I doubt the Dallas he said you know
who'd all-time leading receivers I said
yeah he said okay III know I said I know
who would better be went by the time my
Korean nice because that's why they
drafted me that's why they drafted me so
I I got I get that I made that mark
every morning I woke up rich I'm up
there 88 and thought about your peers
and every time I walked in the stadium I
looked at the guys in the Ring of Honor
and said I will not disrespect you today
you know so so for him if 88 was to pull
something out of him that's great he
said King wanted to wear the number can
I say that's great a desperately I want
to make my own mark that's great
whatever pulls your bear out but I want
him obvious before I let them out that's
all I said get you this I said man you
about to talk about wearing a date
called Terry Jones
it's very persuasive no matter what you
said he's gonna tell you all kinds of
story but he's gonna try to teach you to
see it his way so some when I heard he
was going to wear a tee I reached out to
him I say hey did I tell you he was
persuasive or what you know so we were
laughing about that I'll let him tell
everybody do whatever his dealings were
with Jerry but but I loved it I
absolutely loved it and in the beer and
a towei you have to be fun
that means drafted or signed by the
Cowboys only the Cowboys
bring it as a cowboy I play are born
here I was bring it here and I balled
here and he will meet all of those
criterias because I thought that was the
best receiver in the draft and the best
pickup for Dallas because of what he
does in the positions he can play you
get paid a squat and outside and right
now Dallas has no production from the
slot on the roster right now because
that's going to Houston Texas a rental
car so I mean when it all comes down to
it though it does appear that 88 is now
gonna be a number that is given out to
somebody that that I guess Jerry Jones
feels is special I mean you know
and you are the one you know obviously
others did wear it but from Pearson to
you to DES you know Antonio Bryant had
it a couple years obviously after you
but you know this is this is what it's
turned into as opposed to just being set
aside you you're fine with that right I
know the answer to it I know the answer
to it but I know others might not though
when they hear about this let me tell
them why I'm okay where there is let me
tell them why I don't know why I seem to
be the only people person to see it this
way we may retire your number and they
put that number in the rafters they
don't look that you don't they don't
look they don't talk about that number
until you leave time and go to eternity
okay me doing another game they said
well we lost Michael Irvin today and
your soda number that's all three points
family let's get back to the game but
when they put it on a receivers back
where the time he makes her play on
Sunday they said oh I look like Michael
Irvin Oh Michael Irvin wouldn't it drop
it you see what I see I don't I gotta
get my flowers I get my flowers every in
a Sunday that you are on the field and I
want my flowers while I'm living Michael
Irvin everybody here on the Rich Eisen
show I knew that question would elicit
an answer that was worth asking the
question so um let's talk about des why
is he not playing right now can you give
me an update on him I constantly hit him
with direct messages saying come on come
on the show and let's talk but he's he's
elusive what's going on with him can you
give me an update
earth yeah my mind and what I believe
happened and I know I know some of it
and I'll share a little bit here when
they first got released by the Cowboys
it was like the divorce that he really
did want and he he
he just soured in the ping of it he
soured in the paint I know this because
at the time teams will call and trying
to bring days in stay at all four
there's twenty five thirty million
dollars something like that for a two
three four three year deal Baltimore
offer and Cleveland was read off dad's
would not would not even go in and meet
with some of the teams they had really
look for me called me looking for you
because he really was hoping that the
Cowboys will reconsider and bring him
back I think the pain the pain or not
being a cowboy was so great that he
never set his mind on back plan on
playing football again to someone else
and then a dead time went on and you
know he signed with New Orleans and
heard of the kill agent and and and
people just I just just turned away from
it and you know you just lost those
opportunities but it blows my mind with
with with with the talent that they had
that still had an ability to play
football that he has not been on a
football team since since he got
released from the Cowboys and they were
talks that he would get back on the
Cowboys this year but but maybe drafted
CD lamb and and giving him number 88 or
signaled the end of that so so let's
hope and pray tit that this I hope he
gets an opportunity and I hope he takes
that opportunity and make the most up so
we don't know for sure if he wants to
continue playing football but we can't
he wanted to continue playing with the
Dallas Cowboys right I just don't know
if he's ready to go and play with
someone else and and and that that's
that I don't even know how to think what
that is you know what I mean you're a
young man
you still had opportunity to play
football and and you just love the
Cowboys so much you didn't want to go
play very well since and you're left 25
or 30 million dollars on the table at
that pretty amazing she is he healthy
can you get do you know that for short
you know if he's bad yeah he's pretty
healthy you know she'll I see him on
Ellen's been doing his workouts and
everything on Instagram times but yeah
so I know he's healthy talked about
being healthy and talked about it on the
air around here but but just not it just
blows my mind just not getting
opportunities I hope hopefully you will
and
last one for you Michael Irvin we had
Brett Favre on this show last week and
he believes that Aaron Rodgers will
finish his career elsewhere because the
Jordan love drafting says so much of a
writing on the wall would you agree with
that rich man and you know I started to
call you last week when I saw you
stirring all that up everyone is
stirring stirring it up stirring it up I
ask questions people answer them and I
elicit answers with the proper questions
Michael that's the way I would determine
stirring it up that's what they call
stirring it was the Craig question
it was so Apple poke you know you hear
people talk about teachers he's exactly
the person to ask
he's exactly the perfect person to ask
it was deja vu all over again with that
scenario and an absolutely man
absolutely I think even more so now that
Brett has put it out there that is even
more apt to happen when Aaron Rodgers
finishing his career elsewhere and
honestly honestly we're getting to the
time when it's not a big deal anymore
you know the days I think the days of
people facing their career with one team
what I did are with John Elway's guys
like those days are going to be limited
those days are off your ongoing you're
not going to see more of those days
especially after Tom Brady did it you
got guys like LeBron James who makes
bouncing around you know a plausible you
know kind of thing so we we see someone
that start his career wanting and
finished his career with one team that's
going to be the anomaly not the norm not
finishing with the same team is going to
be the north so even if it's the norm or
not or do you think this is the case you
know obviously break down they are
obviously in a fight you know you read a
report where anything
they're kinda tired of being annoyed Raj
you're stuffing all of it so obviously
they're in a fight they're going to be
in a fight
so even when they tell Aaron Rodgers
they think it's time for him to walk
away why do you think he's going to
agree with him he's fighting them the
whole idea of the face they're obviously
in a fight so no matter how great they
complete the work relationship is we're
watching a documentary where it couldn't
have been better than what we're
watching with the boys and they broke
that up because of fighting in house
fighting you see what I'm saying so you
know the one thing and it's funny what
the Bible says that sanity is the
greatest sin and come inside of all it
is is the root sanity
everybody wants the credit for doing
what's happening on the field instead of
everybody saying well we all are doing
it everybody wants to say I'm the one
that's doing it vanity is the greatest
seeing vanity we'll have them finish
elsewhere all right Michael here's a
deal let's put a pin in that because I'm
when the last dance is over in a couple
weeks I'm gonna have you back on I want
to get your two cents on that because I
know you're tight with mitchrichman you
must have Jordan stories and and I want
to get to that but I know joy stories I
mean some dinners Rob this story you
know okay yeah we talked about all that
and then we're gonna have you on in two
weeks two weeks from today I'm having
you on so let's make a note of that
let's that that's now a date
Irv okay two weeks from today absolutely
buddy love ya chat soon appreciate y'all
baby I appreciate you all right take
care
that's Michael Irvin the best Irvin and
Rodman stories very rarely will I tease
a show two weeks yeah sign me up
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here